hey hey hey I'm sorry hey excuse me hey
my Sherpa what's cooking yeah just uh
just might have just touched Bill Gates
huh hey did you check out the acoustics
on my room for my talk did you get me on
the culture hike what did I what did I
get in my Shelley did I get the nut and
fruit box or the champagne and
paperweight nuts yeah but uh but the
talk venue is great it's the same one as
Roman and Ken oh yeah and um and don't
worry about the nuts I mean the the
cashews are the size of boomerangs okay
hey nice vest mom's Gans it's so puffy
think your roaming what's it stuffed
with your hopes and dreams
oh well hiking boots they're pristine oh
here we go
all right all rise for Pope big dick
hello ray mr. right you know what I need
hey hey there yeah just to say I don't
know how to speak you're with all the
details but I'm just say that we're all
lined up for the ATN strategy announced
but yeah same [ __ ] different rapper well
no we're not gonna we're not gonna go
with that banner but we you know we
settled on we're listening it tested
great it tested fine do me a favor is
that sandy from this oh yes yeah yeah
talking oh yeah I know what a bump it
not here not now okay Viper's would love
it well gladly out we'd be honored to be
your talking partners yes so basically
the talk is a celebration of pudding
audience input front and center and
hopefully be really inclusive and quite
change after a recent events because a
TN citizen is essentially very similar
but with the option of
LT he looks it looks a little enfeebled
yeah I had I had maybe maybe syphilis
ones really
and that's necessarily hear much about
syphilis these days very much the the
myspace of STDs
you